responsable en parte del rebrote del cob
y 19 en india y localizada ya en
distintos países
la variante be 1 617 conocida como
variante india preocupa porque desde que
se detectó por primera vez en octubre en
el centro de india se propagó
rápidamente por todo el planeta
es la marca de la segunda ola las nuevas
mutaciones entran en juego y el número
de casos aumenta enormemente porque
también se ve afectada a la población
más jóvenes incluidos los niños es lo
que constatamos en este momento
la variante que se expande en este
momento se califica de doble mutación lo
que significa que contiene dos
mutaciones observadas en otras variantes
mutaciones que convierten el virus en
más contagioso y potencialmente más
resistente a las vacunas desarrolladas
hasta ahora pero no necesariamente más
letal en el momento no tenemos razones
para inquietarlos excesivamente
básicamente porque en proporción al
número de casos no observamos un
incremento en la mortalidad ni síntomas
más graves en los pacientes el número de
a sintomáticos es el mismo que antes
según los científicos el crecimiento
exponencial del número de casos diarios
en índia se explica sobre todo por el
relajamiento de las medidas de
protección individual y por los eventos
multitudinarios de estas últimas semanas